il était présent hier à l'université
versailles saint quentin pour le
lancement de la réforme d'entrée dans
les écoles d'avocats thierry mandon
secrétaire d'état en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche a pu faire un point devant une
centaine d'étudiants sur cette réforme
qui l'a porté à bras le corps on
constate sur le territoire français d
des taux de succès très variable selon
les universités et à cet examen reposait
sur des règles qui finalement faisait
que ceux qui formaient les étudiants
étaient aussi partis à la sélection de
ce qui allait être avocat dont il y
avait des mesures et d'égalité de
justice qui l'imposait
et pour résoudre cette inégalité de
justice thierry mandon a décidé
d'uniformiser l'examen d'entrée dans les
écoles d'avocats
une mesure qui permet d'avoir un
concours d'entrée homogène pour tous les
étudiants
cette réforme répond à un besoin
d'égalité et s'inscrit évidemment dans
une dynamique républicaine d'accès égal
au mieux égale à tous les étudiants à la
profession d'avocat
je crois que un certain nombre de nos
collègues enseignants chercheurs voire
même à responsabilités ont beaucoup plus
vrai dans cette direction ce nouvel
examen unique avec le même sujet pour
tous aura lieu pour la première fois en
septembre 2017